Guys, Donald Trump or Kamala Harris?
Donald Trump, baby,
of course. When? Milk.
I'm just kidding, I'm just kidding.
Kamala Harris or Donald Trump?
Oh, Harris all the way.
Kamala Harris all day. Kamala Harris.
Kamala Harris. Guys, guys.
Donald Trump or Kamala Harris?
Harris, of course.
See, the guys who are like,
I can't vote for a woman,
they're nuts. They go fuck themselves,
period.
The manliest thing you could do is to vote for an accomplished woman
like Kamala. You vote for a woman, girl,
the women are gonna love you.
So am I allowed to? Yes.
She's got way bigger balls than Donald Trump does.
You say to guys who say, I can't vote for a woman,
um, grow up with the 21st century,
you're not gonna get laid. If that's your viewpoint,
I think that's good. Cause you know when they say like, oh,
voting for a woman is gay,
it's like, well,
voting for another dude is way gayer.
Way gayer. Coming from a gay man.
So that's why I'm voting for Trump, personally.